[Musique]
serge gainsbourg c'est d'autant plus
méritoire d'être venu aujourd'hui un
discours à macgé la boissière n'avaient
pas dormi cette nuit mais qu'en
savez-vous ce que je sais c'est pour
travailler beaucoup beaucoup
c'est drôle serge gainsbourg chaque fois
que vous venez à discorama stable pour
une fois par an j'ai l'impression donnée
comme chez le médecin j'ai envie de vous
dire donnez moi votre pouls comment
allez-vous et où en êtes vous
aujourd'hui
oui je suis malade incurable incurable
sûrement malades de je ne crois pas
incurable en quoi incurable lorsque vous
êtes gainsbourg et vous est empêtré
souvent dans les contradictions de
contradictions non évolution en
pollution maintenant vous chanter est un
peu comme un beatles à oopa vous tout
seul
qu'est ce qui est arrivé est arrivé qu
il ya un courant
mondiale qui viennent signer à liverpool
et qu'on ne peut pas ignorer c'est tout
sur 13 5 pour passer sclérosé que tu es
vraiment j'écris des chansons difficile
en 10 chiffres intellectuelle j'écris
des chansons faciles on discute je
sacrifie au commercial
enfin je parle à peine cherche des
noises
enfin il ya quand même quelque chose qui
a fondamentalement changé je me souviens
d'une année je joue il doit y avoir
trois ans vous m'avez dit en parlant des
jeunes gens qui chantaient les très
jeunes
après tout s'ils veulent acheter des
sucettes et fabriquer des suicides à
sucette ou acheter des vagues en sucette
ça les regarde moi ça ne m'intéresse pas
or il se trouve que maintenant vous
écrivez pour tous ces jeunes gens dont
vous disiez janvier
moi aussi maintenant c'est vous qui leur
fabriquer les sucettes ces mêmes vous
lisiez la sucette au gingembre
monsieur certes en ce moment je peux pas
chose pour eddy mitchell coup de
françois
on se garde encore quand vous parlez des
jeunes gens qui chantaient alors ce soit
n'y a pas trois ans mais il ya deux ans
vous me disiez je suis en train de
s'apercevoir que leur maison est un
vêtement pour aller tous les jours
enfin pour eux pour vivre tous les jours
que le revêtement est doublé de vison et
que ce serait peut-être intéressant de
le retourner mais bien oui un jour vous
m'avez dit ça je vais retourner le mien
c'était du plus puissant
vous l'avez retourner alors je voudrais
pas vous attaquer je voudrais simplement
vous poser la question pourquoi elle a
beau retourner votre blouson aves tu
m'as restent bas parce que
je m'en sors comme ça on sort beaucoup
mieux
tu es un ajout
il faut réussir ou alors ceux abandonnés
j'ai fait un calcul très simple un
mathématiques je fais 12 titres mois sur
un 33 tours de prestige
je lis pochette les titres très élaborés
précieux sur ces 12 titres deux passes
au sol sur les antennes et les dix
autant parfaitement ignoré j'ai écrit
deux titres pour douze interprètes
différents et 12 sont douze succès
est-ce que vous iriez jusqu'à dire que
les chansons que vous composez sont les
chansons que vous aimez certainement
certainement oui alors comment cela se
concilie avec votre ancien goût pour le
jazz et surtout pour le jazz moderne
j'aime le jazz moderne mais je ne veux
plus entendre parler dans le sens de la
chanson
il est malsain et akli mal de drogue
dangereux il faut absolument qu'on peut
pas mettre sur le dans le domaine de la
chanson ce possible alors abandonnant
totalement le jazz
mais le roc a même si une rythmique est
très intéressante qui correspond à mon
désir de violence
qui va parfaitement on venait
d'angleterre j'aimerais bien vous
raconter ce que vous avez vu entendu
là-bas parce que on en a quelques échos
mais ce que j'ai tout bon c'est un
courant type dut donc de liverpool ou
les
la femme a une importance dans la
famille très conséquente et où le père
est en retrait à part ça
un milieu de difficiles niveaux de bas
niveaux niveau de vie très bas ce qui
fait que les garçons étaient abandonnés
à eux mêmes pour faire quelque chose de
leur peau ils ont acheté des dédits tard
ils ont fait créer un mouvement qui a
dépassé les frontières les maires
mouvement mondial qu'on ne peut pas
ignorer non on pas l'ignorer mais est-ce
que vous allez continuer dans ce sens là
où est-ce que vous avez un autre
objectif en cliquant sur la chanson
festive que celui ci aucun objectif
celui celui ci pour le moment je n'en
démords aurait pu abaisser le rock qui
dément qui en demandera alors en dehors
du rop qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
chanson en france pas grand chose
pas grand chose c'est à dire
la chanson soi disant intellectuels de
la actuellement et leur neo pour moi au
certificat d'études primaires et encore
ce qu'il ya de plus déprimant quand on
pense au sursaut de de
l'intellectualisme qui avait donné
l'après-guerre avec prévert brassens
leclerc vient et où en est la chanson
dite rive gauche à la rive gauche existe
plus c'est un non sens où en est la
chanson ça n'existe plus alors autant
s'amuser autant faire durant ça c'est
marrant je musicalement session actuelle
c'est quelque chose
quelque chose qui ne prenait plus part
d'entre vous pensez qu entre la chanson
dite intellectuelle et la chansonnette
chance et par claude françois ou par
[Musique]
parra des jeunes pour qu'ils vous
écrivez entre les deux il n'y a rien
voici entre luc de alaric chose demi
prétentieux mimi mais primaire qui donne
le change alors on se rabat dessus parce
que on n'a rien d'autre à se mettre sous
la dent elle qui paraît vaut pas un nom
lui a cédé le maillot pas de nom enfin
vous voyez très satisfait de parler oui
je vois très bien fait vous me
permettrez avoir un avis différent on
souvent
j'ai quand même l'impression que 1 parle
par le fait de gagner votre vie avec la
chanson c'est une activité pour vous qui
un jour avant 15h deviendra une espèce
d'impasse
non pas ça ou suffira à l'impasse dans
le sens de la satisfaction par rapport à
soi
je tourne vers la comédie musicale
puisque j'ai lu que musical pour bouyali
karine pour la télévision et rythm and
blues et rock alors attaqué à la
prétention les faits en vestale story
alors écoutez moi comment ça se passait
trop mais je vous la tournée en ce
moment oui ça se passe en couleurs c'est
très joli succès puis encore un mini
tennis et karina et brian is well well
de très bons interprètes
c'est une histoire d'amour
c'est une histoire d'amour à la chorale
de gaz beau ça n'arrive pas au bout et
ça commence comme ans si ça n'arrive pas
on rencontre toutes les histoires de
rencontres entre qui et qui
entre bouyali et la photo de karine et
la photo une photo il saura jamais que
c'est elle parce que dans la vieille
porte des lunettes
mais c'est très moderne soutenu
c'est très joli alors voilà je glisse
légèrement en dehors de la chanson j'ai
commencé par la peinture dans la vie de
passer à la chanson de certains n'aiment
pas aller ailleurs
bon je vais écrire un bouquin sur enfin
je suis pas assez mignon pousse à
amphion nous avons fait tout ce tour
d'horizon pour en arriver pratiquement à
dire que la chanson c'est pas une chose
très importants dont la chanson n'a
jamais été une chose importante parce
que c'est pas parce qu'il ya
l'auditoire
immense et tous les pays du monde que la
chanson est une chose importante
on se met pas son fauteuil pour écouter
et que la guerre harry vicié et se
termine là il faut des éditoriaux pour
ça n'est pas des les chansonniers
moi je suis absolument contre tout
message
c'est ce que je voulais vous faire dire
je pense qu'en passant de la peinture la
chanson et de la chanson a petitement la
littérature c'est une manière de se
conduire en dilettante à venu le temps
si vous volez j'avais envie de dire des
choses dans un livre je voudrais savoir
quoi joue sur les femmes à maison
expérience personnelle
déception personnelle puis
idéal personnel
très compliqué si vous parlez d'idéal
personnel c'est donc vrai pas tout à
fait tout à fait aussi misogyne que vous
l'étiez les quelques scènes des amis du
zoo gic-g tu dis que c'est tout a très
tendre une patrouille dont il se nourrit
avec ma gueule soit en dur en belgique
ce mec il vient je peux pas être tendre
et dur j'ai une gueule dur je ne peux
pas être tendre je suis tant en privé
pas devant les gens est ce que vous
savez que les autres visages qu'on vous
dit vous avez beaucoup d'années un
triste oui mais ça je le sais mais elles
sont pas idiote je veux dire qu'elles
sont peur
sans faille et à dire et savent très
bien que derrière mes chansons il ya moi
chanson c'est mon métier c'est mon
uniforme mais dans six villes je suis
chez moi même chose autre chose un peu
plus facile
puis pourquoi dire il faut être ceci
faut être souriant il faut pas être dur
il faut être gentil qu'est ce que cette
notion de du rose et gris noir bon dieu
il dans vos cinémas ya des gars
formidable surtout jours très durs que
jack palance on adore ces gars là pour
alors ils ont music-hall ça va partir
les sinistrés il est dur il est méchant
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas voir la vie
une certaine façon toujours rose ciel
bleu pas en vip en méditerranée enfin
moi je ne sais pas si les dieux ou si le
méchant et tout à l'heure je vous ai vu
à les mettre entre cravate
vous avez travers sept studios pour la
chercher pour aller la chercher et vous
marcher d'un pas dansant du soin d'un
homme qui serait tout à fait heureux de
vivre
/
[Musique]